lors de votre journal de l'afrique a à
la une de l'actualité à ce soir le
président tunisien a qui disent on peut
parlement il y avait déjà suspendu l'été
dernier certains élus l'ont défié cet
après-midi en organisant une séance
virtuel nous sommes en direct depuis
tunis pour faire le plein
et nations unis n'excluent aucune piste
plus de 24 heures après la mort de huit
casques bleus les circonstances du drame
ne sont toujours pas connus selon les
premiers résultats de l'enquêté de la
monusco un objet lumineux aurait causé
l'accident
et puis le mois sacré de ramadhan
approche à très grands pas premier jour
du jeûne ce samedi 2 avril
cette année la flambée des prix gâche
quelque peu les célébrations une hausse
due à la guerre dont en ukraine n'est
pas seulement roule vers
le parlement tunisien 10 ou sur ordre du
président kaïs aed une mesure de
représailles après une séance non
autorisé cet après midi certains élus
avaient tenté d'organiser une session
virtuelle la ministre de la justice a
ouvert une enquête pour conspiration
contre la sûreté de l'état trouve tout
de suite en direct depuis tunis lié à
blaise bonsoir à vous à lilia blaise
avec cette décision on peut le dire le
président said est en train de renforcer
encore un peu plus son emprise
alors oui le présent de la république
s'est basé sur l'article 72 de la
constitution et non pas l'article 80
comme je l'aï dit précédemment à
l'antenne je vous prie de m'excuser
l'article 72 qui stipule que le
président de la république et le chef de
l'état est le symbole de son unité qui
garantit son indépendance et sa
continuité et veille au respect de la
constitution
donc en prenant cette décision de
dissoudre le parlement c'est une
interprétation assez large de cet
article mais comme vous l'avez dit c'est
aussi une manière de réaffirmer sur le
plan politique un face à des
parlementaires qui se sont opposés à lui
les parlementaires qui ont voté
l'annulation en fait des décret loi que
le président de la république avait pris
depuis le 25 juillet et les mesures
d'exception qu'il avait mise en place
des parlementaires qui ont voté au nom
de 116 un député sur 217 et qui
aujourd'hui sont poursuivis en justice
d'après les dires du président pour
atteinte à la sûreté de l'état il a
dénoncé dans un discours ce soir ce
qu'il considérait être un complot contre
l'état et il avait également réitéré à
plusieurs reprises hier et en début de
semaine que ce genre de réunion était
illégal il avait même déclaré que le
parlement appartenait au passé et que
quiconque voulait se réunir dans
l'hémicycle devrait le faire à bord d'un
vaisseau spatial on sait déjà mieux ce
qui se passera dans les prochains jours
les prochaines semaines
alors c'est assez difficile de savoir
actuellement ce que va entraîner cette
décision puisqu'elle est surtout
symbolique puisque on le sait depuis
huit mois le parlement tunisien ne
travaillent plus aujourd'hui sur le plan
juridique on ne sait pas si cela va
devoir pousser cassayet d'organiser des
élections législatives anticipées
alors qu'elle était prévue plutôt pour
la fin de l'année il y a aussi ce
référendum qui est prévue cet été sur
des réformes constitutionnelles et
législatives
et puis il ya la question bien sûr de la
situation économique du pays aujourd'hui
la crise politique qui s'enlise en
tunisie comme on peut le voir après
cette décision est une est un problème
finalement pour la crise économique
comme la com ont signalé plusieurs
bailleurs de fonds de la tunisie
actuellement la tunisie est en pleines
négociations avec le fmi pour un prêt
elle a sécurisé également un prêt de 4
milliards d'euros de l'union européenne
et donc cette situation de crise avec
une partie de l'opposition politique
pourrait mettre à mal cette
reconstruction économique du pays et ces
négociations très merci beaucoup lily et
lily à blaise en direct depuis tunis les
nations unies ne désigne aucun
responsable à la monusco n'exclut aucune
piste plus de 24 heures après la mort de
huit soldats de la paix les
circonstances du crash de leur
hélicoptère
elles ne sont toujours pas connues des
enquêtes sont en cours l'armée
congolaise et groupes armés rebelles m23
continuent de s'accuser mutuellement les
précisions de juliette du bois à
kinshasa
la monusco confirmé mercredi que les
débris de l'hélicoptère ont été
retrouvés sur la zone du crash ainsi que
les corps des huit casques bleus qui
étaient à bord il s'agit de six
pakistanais un serbe et un russe qui
effectue est une mission de
reconnaissance dans les territoires de
rutshuru où des combats opposent l'armée
congolaise et le groupe rebelle m23
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
de la monusco sais je cite un objet
lumineux qui aurait causé l'accident la
force de l'onu une exclu pour l'instant
aucune piste attac ou accident et
travaille déjà sur le site du crash est
notre priorité hier c'était donc de
ramener les corps sur goma ce qu'on a
fait et au moment où nous sommes donc
nous sommes en train de nous activer
pour pouvoir faire rapatrier les corps
le plus rapidement possible dans leur
pays d'origine l'enquète est déjà lancée
dans le service vous savez y aura
plusieurs niveaux d' enquête il y aura
une enquête préliminaire pour déterminer
exactement ce qui s'est passé à
l'instant il y aura une enquête plus
approfondie parce qu'il ya également des
questions de sûreté d'aviation également
il y aura aussi des enquêtes pour
déterminer
qu'est ce qui a causé cet accident les
forces armées de rdc ont rapidement
accusé les rebelles du m23 d'avoir
abattu l'appareil le groupe armé a
démenti accusant au contraire l'armée
d'être responsables du crash les combats
dans la zone de l'incident ont commencé
dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi et ont
continué mardi dans plusieurs localités
du territoire de rutshuru le m23 qui
avait déposé les armes en 2013 est de
nouveau actif au nord kivu depuis
novembre ses membres ont attaqué à
plusieurs reprises des positions de
l'armée congolaise le secrétaire général
de l'onu se dit profondément préoccupé
par la résurgence des activités du m23
dans cette zone frontalière entre le
rwanda la rdc et l'ouganda
dans le reste de l'actualité en bref et
en images la mauritanie où la démission
du premier ministre mende ould bilal a
été rendu avant ce fait à la télévision
nationale aucune déclaration suite
devant après son s'est en revanche que
la semaine passée le président rabbani
avait sévèrement critiqué le travail du
gouvernement le premier ministre
démissionnaire a de nouveau été chargé
par le président de former une nouvelle
équipe
l'escale dans tony blinken alger reçu
par le président teboul une façon sans
doute de sécuriser une partie de
l'approvisionnement en énergie si la
russie couper le gaz est le chef de la
diplomatie américaine était la veille à
rabat le sahara occidental a été évoquée
avec nasser bourita le ministre marocain
des affaires étrangères et les etats
unis ont réitéré leur soutien au plan
d'autonomie présenté par le maroc
le coût de la vie chère de plus en plus
élevés autobond les prix du carburant
s'envole puisse 20% pour le sample an
+30 7% pour le pétrole lampant très
consommée dans les fermes et les
villages le gouvernement s'est justifié
en expliquant que la conjoncture
actuelle impose et ses os référence là
encore à la guerre en ukraine
le mois sacré de ramadhan approche à
très grands pas premier jour du jeûne ce
samedi 2 avril lé repas du soir sont
traditionnellement partager avec
l'ensemble de la famille avec les amis
également l mais cette année la flambée
des prix gâche quelque peu les
célébrations une hausse due au conflit
en ukraine mais pas seulement
illustration sénégal avec le renverse
cher
dans ce marché de dakar les clients
hésitent comparer soupèse avant de se
décider à acheter
car au sénégal les prix des produits de
première nécessité n'arrête pas de
grimper suscitant l'inquiétude à
quelques jours du ramadan
rien est abordable actuellement tous les
aliments sont chers avant un sac de chou
comptait huit mille francs cfa mais
aujourd'hui ils coûtent presque baril
francs et c'est pareil pour tous les
produits
plusieurs facteurs ont contribué à cette
hausse la période d'abord car chaque
année les prix grimpent à la proche du
ramadan l'économie ensuite avec une
inflation qui ne cesse d'augmenter
depuis un an alors que le pays peine à
se remettre de la pandémie de covin 19
enfin la guerre en ukraine qui a impacté
les prix des denrées un peu partout en
afrique mais pour nombre de sénégalais
la crise actuelle est surtout la
conséquence des fermetures des
frontières avec le mali voisin
en septembre le gouvernement sénégalais
avait annoncé plusieurs mesures pour
tenter de terminer à hausse des prix
notamment la baisse ou l'annulation des
taxes et droits de douane sur certains
produits des mesures qui n'ont pour
l'instant pas réellement porté leurs
fruits
petit rappel des équipes qualifiées pour
le mondial cinq nations africaines iront
représenter le continent à doha au qatar
ghana sénégal tunisie maroc et cameroun
après la défaite de son équipe la
fédération égyptienne de foot a déposé
une plainte contre le sénégal pour
violence et racisme la caf et la fifa
n'ont pas encore donné de réponse
officielle
populaire que le foot le skateboard
reste un sport marginal en afrique
comptait seulement disque et de park sur
tout le continent mais quelques
passionnés comme la jeune harmonie à
bata cas multiplient des efforts pour
recruter de nouveaux adhérents de
nouvelles adhérentes cap sur le ghana
avec charles pellegrin
avant le skate c'était le dimanche mais
même en harmonie a fait le choix de
vivre sa passion à plein temps
j'avais économisé de l'argent avec mon
ancien travail
donc j'ai décidé que même si je n'avais
plus du tout de revenus je voulais être
libre et faire ce que j'aime
une passion partagée par de plus en plus
de monde surtout après l'ouverture du
premier skate park au ghana l'année
dernière c'est ici qu'elle a trouvé son
nouveau travail elle enseigne les bases
du skate particulièrement aux jeunes
femmes elle fait partie du collectif
skate galfione
je suis juste tellement heureuse qu'il y
ait autant de filles qui veulent essayer
même si elles ne veulent pas continuer
au moins elles tentent
tous les jeudis le parc est ouvert
exclusivement aux femmes elles peuvent
utiliser tous les équipements
gratuitement une opportunité en or pour
lille à quatre ans après seulement
quelques mois elle a réussi à dompter la
plus grosse vente du parc est aussi ses
peurs n'ai pas peur ça va aller je suis
là fais moi confiance je t'attrape ray
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi merci de votre
fidélité à nos chefs
[Musique]